johannesburg théâtre d'une scène inédite
face au président sud africain des
militaires chante et acclament leur chef
d'état pourtant malgré cette liesse
apparente
la situation devient critique en afrique
du sud notre pays n'a jamais traversé
une période comme celle ci c'est sans
précédent non seulement dans notre
démocratie mais aussi dans l'histoire de
notre pays
ce qu'on finit pendant 21 jours pour
aller faire la guerre à un ennemi
invisible le coronavirus
le pays a ainsi rejoint les 3 milliards
de personnes dans le monde déjà appelés
à rester chez elle
premier pays d'afrique à imposer le
confinement total l'afrique du sud
s'appuie sur le soutien de l'armée pour
assurer son application un confinement
qui vient renforcer les dernières
mesures drastiques prises par le
gouvernement
vente d'alcool et de cigarettes prohibée
tout comme promener son chien
seul l'achat des produits de première
nécessité est autorisée être obligé de
se confiner est un problème préoccupant
mais je pense que c'est surtout pour
contenir le virus qui se propage dans le
pays
c'est très triste surtout pour les gens
qui vivent au jour le jour
j'ai l'autorisation d'aller travailler
mais cela a été un processus très
difficile
nous allons travailler pour certains
d'entre nous et nous mettons nos vies en
danger
mais au bout du compte il y a des gens
qui ont besoin de nos services et le
président fait ce qu'il a dit il n'y a
pas d'autre choix que de contrôler le
pays de cette façon car la population
sait qu'elle doit avoir une vie après
cela quand certains continuent d'aller
travailler
d'autres ont choisi de se mettre à
l'abri en famille un exode étroitement
surveillés par les personnels soignants
nous faisons juste un test coville 19
juste pour vérifier si vous allez bien
si vous avez besoin d aide si nous
pouvons vous en voyez faire des tests
des choses comme ça ce que nous
cherchons c'est de savoir d'où venez
vous allez si vous avez été en contact
avec quelqu'un que vous connaîtriez qui
est le co vide 19 une mesure de
confinement total qui risque de
bouleverser l'organisation du pays
le gouvernement exige l'appliquer
partout y compris dans les bidonvilles
très nombreux en afrique du sud les sud
africains redoutent les ravages du
nouveau coronavirus si l'épidémie
prolifèrent dans ces quartiers déjà
fortement touchée par le vih et la
tuberculose